now then British ground troops could be
sent to Libya in the future the Foreign
Secretary has hinted in an interview
with The Sunday Telegraph Philip Hammond
said he wouldn't rule anything out Libya
is expected to be on the agenda David
Cameron and Barack Obama meet other g5
leaders tomorrow what Christian
conservative chair of the influential
Foreign Affairs Committee he's in hawley
in Surrey and a very good morning to you
so is the Foreign Secretary getting
closer to committing formal British
ground forces well it sounds that way
we've got to remember this proposition
has been kicking around for over six
months around a Ground Force going into
Tripoli initially its mission was going
to be to deliver security on the ground
for an incoming new government they then
realize that was a pretty bad idea so
the mission changed or the concept of
operations changed to training Libyans
to provide that security but that was
training was going to be provided from
inside Tripoli which when the Foreign
Affairs Committee was briefed on it we
thought was a particularly bad idea
there is a need to get security for that
government as a need for Libyans to
provide it that problem as obviously
will not go away and there's a need to
deal with the growing threats and hold
of is and indeed then the the refugee
dimension as well wood wood wood ground
forces help there or wouldn't they just
get sucked in be potential targets
potential hostages and things like that
well it's already been widely reported
around the actions of French Special
Forces assisting some libyan national
army under the command of this brigadier
heft are have been successfully removing
Islamic state forces from areas around
Benghazi you're quite right there's a
big challenge round cert so-called
Islamic state is an enemy of all of us
and it's absolutely in our interest they
should be removed there's pretty strong
speculation that British special forces
are involved here as well now exactly
what the ground element should be well
the air
of any campaign should be what the sea
element of interdiction of migrants
ought to be are all open questions and
you can see from that the complexity of
the challenges that are being faced by
the international community but the
international community needs to act
together it needs to act under the
coordination of the UN secretary-general
special representative who's done a
pretty good job in nudging this new
compromise government agreed pretty much
by both sides into reality and the
British government needs to take
Parliament with it i think parliament
will be quite sympathetic to the
challenges the government faces but if
were not told anything and were given a
concept of operations that looks pretty
dangerous and just around the ground
element then i think the government
could find itself getting into
unnecessary trouble ok i'm not sure if
we lost contact there mr. let me try
another question then are you saying
then because this was being perhaps
suggested we buy they buy the defense
secretary that some the House of Commons
must have a vote if there's to be any
sizable deployment will you then get
this rather peculiar situation where
both the defense secretary and the
foreign sectors foot so far as I can
tell last week was saying that a
training deployment into a combat zone
didn't require a parliamentary vote but
you would require a parliamentary wrote
to do something eminently sensible like
providing air power in support of Libyan
forces attacking our common enemy on
Islamic state and then what would be the
status of sea operations going into
Libyan territorial waters to halt the
migrant flow and get get into Libya and
territorial waters say would return the
migrants to Libya itself all of these
are obviously complex and I think the
more transparent the government could be
about the challenge it faces and trying
to take Parliament's and the public with
it in getting a sensible strategy here
acknowledging that they've got to work
with the international community I think
that would be better rather than this
these rather curious and
difficult nostrils about when and when
not parliamentary or authority is
required and so we've got this g5 summit
tomorrow Libya going to loom large in
that it's going to be an interesting
conversation if one hasn't already taken
place between President Obama and Mr
Cameron about the issue of Libya because
we know President Obama's views that
Europe as a whole messed it up and Mr
Cameron in particular took his eye off
the ball well I think President Obama
obviously made his views clear and array
lengthy interview the Atlantic Journal
it was only a small part of that and I
think he's also said subsequently it's
the foreign policy issue that caused the
biggest regret to him and Sons I
attended the case that Libya is
infinitely worse off now than it was
before we at our intervention in 2011
now my committee is doing a full inquiry
into Libya we've taken a lot of evidence
around the intervention around the
period between post the intervention and
we're now examining policy that ought to
take place and now and we will have
obviously more to say on this in a in a
complete way when we've approved a
report mr. blum thank you very much
indeed Crispin about their chairman of
the Foreign Affairs Select Committee